-Sarah, you've done some amazing
impressions on the show before,
and with that in mind,
I'm about to play
a brand-new game called
"Guess the Impression."
-♪ Guess the impression ♪
♪ Guess the impression ♪
-Oh, that was a good one.
So, in front of each of us
is a stack of cards...
-I'm nervous.
-...with celebrities' names
on them.
Now, on your turn,
you draw a card
and you have to do an impression
of whoever it is on the card,
trying to get the other person
to guess.
And you want to get
the other player to guess
as many as possible
before the timer runs out.
-Okay, but full disclosure --
these don't have to be, like,
our arsenal of magic action.
This can just be
whatever happens.
I don't know what's in the box.
-Yeah, I have not --
-"What's in the box, Larry?
What's in the box?" Okay.
-Wait. That's not
a first one, right?
-No, it isn't.
-Alright, here we go.
No, these are not --
I don't know what names are on.
You don't know these, either.
-Nope.
-These aren't
our go-to impressions.
-Correct.
-Alight. You're up first.
Ready, set --
I'm gonna try to guess.
Go.
-Okay.
♪ If you believe
in love after love ♪
-Oh, that's Cher.
That's Cher all the way.
-Thank you. Okay.
-"Um, uh, all right,
all right, all right!"
-Matthew McConaughey?
-Yes.
"Um, My name --
Uh, I'm Bond. James Bond."
-Oh, Sean Connery?
-Yes.
-Wow.
-Ohh.
"Um, I may be the greatest
actress in the world
and also known as the..."
-Meryl Streep.
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-She goes up and she goes down.
-She goes up and down.
-I don't know
how to do this person.
[ Guttural squeaking ]
-Rudy Giuliani?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Guttural squeaking ]
-Ooh, an eagle.
-No, no.
-Oh, Yoda! Yoda!
-Yes!
-Oh, my God. An eagle.
Oh, my -- I don't know.
He never said that ever
in his life.
-Um. Oh, God. Um...
[Bleep]
Can I not say that?
-It's too late now.
-Um, pass, pass.
-Okay.
-Um...
[ Buzzer sounds ]
"Get out of my --"
[Bleep]
-Oh, my God.
We got to bleep you out.
What an awful turn
it took at the end.
-Sorry.
-You can't even say who it was?
-It was Anne Hathaway.
It was Anne Hathaway.
I didn't know how to --
What would you do?
I mean, I was trying to think
of the song from "Les Mis."
-Oh, yes. Yeah.
I can't even think of the song.
-Was gonna say "I dream
a dream of days gone by,"
but that wasn't it.
Was it?
♪ Make life worth living ♪
-Yes, it was.
-Oh, see?
Would you have gotten it,
though?
-No.
-No, I would not have.
-Fantastic.
-Okay, this is my turn.
Ready for this?
60 seconds. I'm gonna go fast.
Here we go.
"Uh, uh, one percent!
Uh, the rich are too rich!"
-What?
-"We need a bigger
middle class!"
-Oh, Bernie Sanders.
-Yes. Yeah.
"Raise the ball and put the ball
in the basket, chief."
-Oh, it's Jack Nicholson.
-Yes.
Okay, very good.
Uh, okay. Oh, gosh.
"I'm a comedian,
but I talk like this sometimes.
What -- How do we see a doctor
but a doctor
couldn't see a patient?"
-Oh, God!
-"A patient couldn't see
a doctor, but the doc--"
Or something like that. No?
Okay, pass. John Mulaney.
Okay. Um. Oh.
"This guy talks like that.
And then he gets very dark
like that.
And then he gets loud!
He talks like that!
Batman!"
He was in --
And he does the thing --
And he --
[ Inhales sharply ]
Then he gets really
screwed up on...
huffing and kids...."
[ Buzzer sounds twice ]
Don't give me two buzzes!
How rude.
-You go --
[ Mimics Jimmy ]
-No.
-I did not know.
-Wasn't he in
"Cider House Rules"?
[ Inhales sharply ] "All
you kids get to bed now. You --"
-Michael Caine?
-[ Muttering ]
"Of course.
He talks like that."
-[British accent] That is
better. That one's better.
That's my Adele.
It's not very good.
Well, it's sort of my Adele.
-It's like your Adele...
"and my Michael Caine together."
-My Adele and your Michael Caine
are both terrible!
-Sarah Paulson,
for this last round,
we're gonna see how many
we can get together.
-Okay.
-Ready? We got this. Go.
-"Get out of my kitchen!
You're the worst cook in world!"
-Adele.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh! Gordon Ramsey!
-Yes!
-Uh, okay. Okay.
"I eat spaghetti dinners
with my daughter."
Did I say his name?
-You didn't say his name.
-No, I didn't say his name.
-"Spaghetti dinners
with my daughter."
You're Tony Soprano. You're --
-"Every afternoon, I'm gonna
talk to you guys about
what's happening here in
the city and my brother's --
My brother's on TV."
-Oh. Cuomo?
-Yes, yes.
Sorry for that.
Go, go, go. Sorry. It was bad.
-Um. "Oh, God. Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Uh." Ohh-ho-ho. Um...
Now I will --
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
"Uhh. I don't know, man.
Yeah, man.
-"Uhh, I don't know."
-"I've got a brother
who's also an actor."
-What?
[ Buzzer sounds ]
[ Laughter ]
What? Wait. A brother.
-"I don't know, man."
I think it's not bad
for never having done it.
-Oh! Owen Wilson.
-I think it went pretty good.
-Not bad.
That was actually pretty good.
-It was not bad. Like...
-"I don't know, man."
-Took me a minute.
-That's a very good impression.
-It's not bad.
It's not bad having never
done it. Never seen...
-My Cuomo was terrible.
But I didn't know
what else to say.
-Cuomo, you seemed a little
like Tony Soprano
and then ate Alec Baldwin and
also something else happened.
-I was --
-"I'll be back!"
"Hasta la vista, baby!"
-I just wanted to hear more
of it. I love it so much.
-"Hasta la vista, baby!"
-"Baby!"
Dude, I want someone
to remix that
and make that
into a dance classic.
-♪ Hasta la vista, baby! ♪
♪ Hasta la vista, baby! ♪
-That was so much fun.
Sarah Paulson, everybody!
Her new movie, "Run,"
is out on Hulu tomorrow!